i think so i think i think it's good to
be provocative but that's what we wanted
to do
with the book is present those kinds of
questions you could have about the
universe
the why questions of course are always
somewhat dangerous questions to head
into but i think the way you can talk
about it is being based in physics right
i mean i want to understand the physical
process by which
our universe came into being
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
professor jared
lewis
who is
i believe
an award-winning astrophysicist he is a
professor of astrophysics at the sydney
institute for astronomy
way i i've been told i had on somebody
recently who was australian actually a
few australians had brian schmidt on
he's american and then i um i had
somebody else on and i said down under
and and they said you guys don't like
that although you're not originally
australian if i recall correctly you're
british right i i'm british i've been in
australia now for the last 22 years
though so i'm i'm a citizen
but uh yeah yeah i don't mind the phrase
down under we are a long way from
just about anywhere else
yeah
that's true yeah uh i've uh i've noticed
many many many times that uh you know
it's the place that people most want to
visit but uh kind of put it on their
bucket list for for later after the
pandemic subsides made that come soon
and today we're on the podcast you were
last on way back in 2020 with your uh
co-author i believe it was yours was he
your student luke barnes
he was originally my master student so
that was a long time ago
and luke and you were on last time for
the cosmic revolutionaries handbook uh
that was a lot of fun that book to read
and to go over with you we did a live
stream you guys can find that way back
in the archives of the into the
impossible podcast but today we're on to
talk about this magnificent new book
called
where did the universe come from which
immediately like cosmic revolutionary
handbook i think your master at titles
and we always like to begin
conversations with authors uh with a
segment that we call judging books by
their covers
so we have
now to do what you're never supposed to
do which is to assess
a tome by its plumage
where does the title come from and where
does the cover image and illustration
come from and first we should mention
this is written with your author chris
ferry is that how you say his name yes
chris ferry who's at the university of
technology in sydney uh
yeah so
like like all these things though titles
and covers are now workshopped a lot
right with your publisher because
uh
whatever your original title is they
they they talk to people and they they
sort of say what what grabs your
attention and as you know this entire
scientific book market is quite a busy
marketplace these days and i think that
there's a feeling amongst the publishers
is you've got to have a flashy cover
you've got to have an attractive plumage
if you're going to get anybody to pick
up the book
and i feel like when i go into a
bookstore now and i just see the wall of
science books and even i stand there
going i don't even know where to start
anymore
yeah a couple years ago the fad was to
have very dark and ominous covers this
one's kind of dark but not not as dark
as other covers your last book cosmic
revolutionary's handbook is bright
with a fist raised in the air
anticipating you know kind of the
reaction uh that that many would have in
delight raising and pumping their fist
in the air but uh but this one is uh
kind of evocative maybe the galaxy maybe
some weird wave forms and i guess i want
to start with the title although yeah as
you say you know authors rarely have a
chance to contribute to the to the cover
art or the design but but sometimes they
let us choose the the title but um but
maybe in this case the the question i
most have is that w question the where
question
i've heard said you should never ask
questions about that begin with why why
in science uh i never heard you know an
opposition to using where though um what
does it mean where
did the cosmos come from doesn't that
presuppose there was a something there
was a time there was a cosmos
proto-cosmos uh isn't this quite
provocative to uh to start a book with
such a question
i think so and i think i think it's good
to be provocative but that's what we
wanted to do
with the book is present those kinds of
questions you could have about the
universe
the why questions of course are always
somewhat dangerous questions to head
into but i think the way you can talk
about it is being based in physics right
i mean i want to understand the physical
process by which
our universe came into being now i i
like uh like many
uh
books that start with the question
doesn't necessarily mean we've got all
the answers inside the cover but of
course
you you know and your listeners know
that there's there's more than one
single idea about where the universe
came from and
was there a before or what was there a
universe from nothing and we just wanted
to bring some of those ideas in because
the sort of central theme of the book is
bringing together notions of cosmology
the large-scale universe with notions of
quantum mechanics which is often the
small-scale universe and of course that
where did the universe come from is tied
up in the two of them
somehow and that's what we've still got
to work out
and when i look at uh kind of some of
the subheadings and the chapters
it's a small book it's not it's a dense
book it has lovely illustrations and a
lot of good humor and i think you know
it presupposes
a lot of questions that we as working
cosmologists get asked um and yet it
doesn't fully leave the reader with the
sense that everything's known that could
be known in fact there is a chapter that
you entitled towards the end you know do
we know everything or will we ever stop
running out of things to to learn now i
never like to give away the ending of
the book especially when it's like a
novel i had on chris hadfield the
astronaut who wrote a murder mystery and
you know that it was really hard to
interview somebody about a fiction but
uh here it's less uh it's less
controversial let me ask you um
isn't it true that as wheeler said you
know kind of the more that that island
of knowledge expands the more the
boundary the coastline of ignorance also
expands but of course area increases you
know more rapidly than
than boundary but are we learning more
than we're then we're you know uh
revealing uh our ignorance about or are
we really you know kind of uh losing the
game against this infinite ocean of of
ignorance
oh i mean that's such a such a tough
question to answer i mean i'm i am i am
reasonably sure that you know that we
will never you know put stamp our fist
on table and say right we're done
physics is done we now know everything
because even if we you know even if we
get hold of that theory of everything
that people have spoken about now for
almost 100 years right um there will
still be so many questions there to
solve so
we will not know everything but i i do
feel confident that we will know more i
mean that that's that that's definitely
certain but um
the as you said the the shoreline of
ignorance that is that is going to
continue
to to expand and and i have a feeling
that some of the things that you know um
people say are outside the bounds of
science today and metaphysics et cetera
that those things are going to be drawn
in questions of like you know what was
before the universe are there other
universes out there etc they might
become mainstream
um science down the road but it's very
hard to predict the future right
yeah and especially you know that's a
yogi bear said it's it's tough to make
predictions especially about the future
yeah now some of these questions do have
well-defined answers and i think uh as
scientists have learned more and more
about uh different topics especially you
think about the life in the universe and
and so forth which maybe we'll get a
chance to get into but certainly in you
know the stellar astrophysics the the
the notion of you know the the lifetime
and the life line of stars uh black
holes etc these are becoming more and
more
precise and accurate as we develop but
and yet the more that we dig down deeper
into the theme that really runs and
resonates throughout this book is kind
of this overarching notion of the
quantum and i don't know if that was
intentional but the book is kind of uh
it seems to me like a primer
it's portraying and and and and
parlaying our notions of classical
mechanics and classical astrophysics
into what we don't know which is largely
in the quantum realm
and there i feel like uh it may be kind
of hopeless but you know
you can hear any kind of quote that you
like but you know richard feynman anyone
who says they understand quantum
mechanics that you know doesn't
understand quantum mechanics um and with
the proliferation of books about the
interpretation of quantum mechanics
different uh different schools of
thinking
do you feel like quantum mechanics needs
to be really refined and understood
before we can have quantum cosmology
quantum
properties of of black holes for example
do we first need to make basic bedrock
advances in quantum theory that we teach
to undergraduates before we can build on
to it a scaffolding to go into
applications and astronauts
yeah so that
that is one area that i i wanted to try
and sort of stay away from slightly was
the overall interpretation because we
know that um whilst there are varying
interpretations that the mathematics
works exceedingly well right um but you
have to you have to let something go in
your sort of common sense uh to come up
with a description of um
you know
just what is
really happening what are the
mathematics really describing
and i
i do feel that
something has to change
somewhere with our
with our overall philosophical
understanding of quantum mechanics i i
feel that you know that people have been
shouting to each other for for many
years about what the right
interpretation is i actually just went
and reread an old book by john gribbing
called
in search of schrodinger's kittens i'm
not sure if you've
read that one yeah i remember that i
don't know if i read but yeah but it the
final couple of chapters uh settles on
this description of quantum mechanics
which comes from feynman and wheeler of
course the transactional idea where
essentially quantum mechanics works
because signals are sent backwards and
forwards in time right there there isn't
just this forward propagation things
talk through time and of course
the mathematics all works etc but that
interpretation just makes everybody feel
really uncomfortable it doesn't sound
right that you get signals traveling
through time
but the universe doesn't care about what
we feel is right right it's it's just
the way that it works and
i i still don't know what needs to be
done though for one interpretation to be
separated from another to say that this
is the better description of quantum
mechanics but i do feel like something
needs to happen even though it's very
very successful
um
something's waiting in the wings that
will change the way quantum mechanics
will be thought about and applied
so we will get towards that
theory of everything such that we can
talk about the quantum aspects of black
holes the quantum aspects of the birth
of the universe etc those things which
are currently hidden from us
yeah and sometimes i push back you know
as i will with you with respect and
dignity that you deserve but even with
roger penrose and i'll say look the only
times we talk about things where we need
a quantum theory of gravity have to do
with you know singularities and black
holes and and the origin of the universe
if there was a singularity which many
people dispute including sir roger right
so what do you say to people like that
that yes there is a great you know hope
that you know we can unify quantum
mechanics and gravity uh but there's no
letter from god or from zeus or i don't
know whoever from us i don't there's no
letter that guarantees that we have to
unify them so um do you feel like you
know there is kind of an over abundance
of these you know theories of everything
unification there's there's half a dozen
or more that i can uh point to just on
my channel alone um but you know is that
really you know kind of the the richness
uh is it a over abundance of riches in
that one
aspect of physics versus devoting it to
all the quantitative you know there's
there's no need for you know quantum
thermodynamics or you know some new
interpretation of i you know works quite
well and and it's featured in the book
so do we have an oversupply and under
demand for these theories of everything
oh so so again
i think i'm going to trade carefully
here right because i think
um i actually think there's a couple of
things with the theory of everything
right so so firstly there would be the
the
the personal satisfaction that we could
crack that problem if it can be cracked
we don't even know if there really is a
theory of everything right but if we
know physics would sort of go oh yeah
look how smart we are we've actually
worked
this out
but you know as you said there are you
know there's more than one
contender on the table for a theory of
everything but in terms of the physics
effort worldwide
you know this makes up a tiny fraction
of a tiny fraction of a percent of the
effort most physicists around the world
are solid state physicists etc working
on practical problems every day they
probably don't think about or even need
a theory of everything so i don't think
i don't think we're putting a huge
effort into that area i think that that
area gets um a lot more
uh
a lot more attention from the media then
you know
the effort actually uh uh
generates but of course one of the other
things is if we if we get this theory of
everything right if it exists and we do
say oh i i now understand the center of
a black hole and i now understand the
start of the universe
that doesn't mean that it won't open
other doors
to our understanding about what's going
on in the universe right we we we have
this overall picture about
let's just take cosmology right standard
cosmology written in the language of um
einstein's general theory of relativity
and as cosmologists we use this stuff
every day calculate distances red shifts
we're all happy with it and we know that
it can't be complete because there isn't
quantum mechanics in there and we have
mysteries out there and some people have
claimed right that dark energy and dark
matter is the fact that we've got
relativity wrong that we are missing
something relativity
i i'm not
in that particular camp but there is a
vocal group who are
and
if we have that overall theory we we
should be able to say whether or not
dark energy is an illusion because we've
forgotten something quantum mechanical
in cosmology
or if it's a substance that's out there
in the universe that we should go
hunting for so there should be other
questions that we can solve hopefully
but again we're trying to predict the
future here and we know how difficult
that is right
so one of the themes that runs through
the book has to do with symmetries and
kind of guiding principles but where i
often you know find the subject matter
sort of lacking
is that we really care about the broken
symmetries as you point out in the book
uh you and uh chris point out that you
know we're they're perfect symmetries
you know we wouldn't be here almost any
every symmetry has uh the capability for
for being perfect and yet if any of them
were i think
we wouldn't be here so let's take um
matter antimatter you know symmetry uh
and there is a you know thankfully apart
for billion level asymmetry again we
believe we're made of matter and we you
know but that's arbitrary we can't call
ourselves matter but we're really
anti-man it doesn't matter
no pun intended uh there
the uh the opposite uh symmetry isn't
perfect um you had a nice twitter thread
that i kind of
used in one of my videos solo videos on
my youtube channel about the maximal
violation of cp violation i think you go
through it in the book and i wonder if
you could take the readers through it as
well what is cp violation what does it
mean that it's violated
unlike say electric charge which we
don't believe is violated we think
there's symmetry between uh positive and
negative charges uh and locally between
matter and anti-matter but what what is
violated what is cp violation and why is
it so important both to our existence
but also guiding principles in physics
in general yeah
so
yeah so this this is again the
symmetries thing i think this is
uh one of the most beautiful things in
physics which most students don't get to
see until their later university years
and
even when i first encountered symmetries
and breaking symmetries and all kind of
stuff
it didn't really hit me about what was
being said here and it was only a long
time after that that i suddenly realized
how important this is right you know you
get to narrator's theorem and you
suddenly go
that's why something's conserved now i
understand that
so you've you've got our universe you
you have stuff in it and you can ask
about doing
particular
transformations right so symmetry
transformations so you know you can
replace
uh you can take all the positive charges
and make them negative take all the
negative charges and make them positive
and you'd sort of think right everything
should work out to be the same right
we've arbitrarily
labeled positive and negative everything
should work out to be the same right so
with electromagnetism that doesn't
really matter
we also with gravity and the strong
force perfectly happy when it comes to
flipping around charges etc
the the one where things gets really
weird is so this the c in
uh cp symmetry is charge symmetry if i
change positives negative
the one where things get really weird is
the p
which is known as parity
violation right so we're talking about
another symmetry
and
again this was all done in the 1950s and
i think it's a huge disservice to
physics that we don't talk about this a
lot more is that the work that was done
by yang and lee in terms of the theory
and wu in terms of of the experiment
experimentation
so essentially all parity violation is
is you say to yourself right i look at
the universe around me it's all behaving
the way it is and if i imagine that
instead i was looking at the universe
but viewed in a mirror so i'm just
watching a mirror flip you would expect
that the view that you see in the mirror
would be perfectly fine it would all be
very happy and you would say right
everything that's going on in the mirror
that i can expect to see that in this
universe
except when it comes to
one of the fundamental forces of nature
and that's the weak force
so the weak force is um you know it's in
there in the mix of strong
electromagnetism and weak and so there's
like the quantum forces and you also
have gravity
and what yangon lee
basically suggested is that they looked
at all the evidence for
uh weak interactions and they said well
it doesn't
you know the weak force doesn't seem to
need to obey this
parity
uh symmetry i.e if i have an
electromagnetic interaction
and i look at it and i look at it in a
mirror both are physically things that
can occur
but if i take a weak interaction
and i look at it in a mirror the version
that i see in the mirror is something
that doesn't actually occur in our
universe
and this is what wu showed in in her
famous experiments is that she was
looking at the decay of uh i think it's
cobalt into nickel right so it spits out
uh an electron or a positron so it's a
weak sort of process so what you get is
you get your
big nucleus spin in your head spins in a
certain direction
and it tends to spit the the electron
out in a certain direction and a
neutrino comes out in the other
direction
and when you look at that in the mirror
that's not something that occurs in our
universe
so the weak force basically
breaks that parity violation that's it
breaks that parity symmetry
and again that's rather earth-shattering
because in your mind
why should the universe
know about whether or not something has
an acceptable view in a mirror not
essentially what you're saying is the
universe knows its rights from its left
which
seems very weird when you think about it
so you know the there was a hope
that if you had
a
charge
uh symmetry
and a
charged transformation and a parity
transformation that that would give you
back a view of things that occur in this
universe so not only do i look in the
mirror but i change all the positive
signs to negative signs etc that should
get me back to what i see in in this
universe right a simple example would be
a wire that has current flowing through
it if you reverse uh if you reverse the
charges so now it's electrons are
running instead of proto protons are
running through instead of electrons but
you also have to reverse the direction
that those objects are traveling you'll
get the same amount of charge uh
traveling per unit time that's right so
everything then works out but of course
then there are experiments that people
have done now to show that that
combination of c and p together and the
experiments are kind of involved but you
know when you sit down and you work
through them um you sort of find that
even that c and p are violated in
certain
experiments
and again you have to wonder why is the
universe fractured in that way right
there there's a fracture in there and
it's
it's
it's written somewhere into the laws of
physics it didn't have to be there the
universe could be perfectly symmetric in
in that particular um two quantities and
now of course there's a hope that it's
a charge transformation a parity
transformation and a time transformation
so you flip everything in terms of time
that that will restore everything in
terms of
what i see in my mirror and what i see
in the universe
but it's not guaranteed right it's not
going to there's a hope that cpt is
going to be
perfectly
symmetric and
i think it's what you know we are almost
heading off into the realms of that
metaphysical area right you know it you
know why is the universe this way
but to me it is a
somewhat uncomfortable kind of thing
in that we know as you said at the start
if our universe was perfectly symmetric
so it was born with
no matter at all we wouldn't be here
okay
so there's a one part in a billion that
a symmetry between a matter of
antimatter that allows us to be here
if that difference of one part in a
billion was also there in charge
conservation
the universe would be a complete mess
right if charge could appear and
disappear at random around the universe
you know things would be highly chaotic
so why is charge perfectly
symmetric and matter
slightly fractured
and we just don't know the answers we
can write terms into our equations but
we don't know why it's that way
yeah
um
exactly
so what's so fascinating about these you
know broken symmetries is that in the
case of matter antimatter as you just
said you know if they're equal amounts
we wouldn't be here and the amount of
violation is incredibly small and that
allows us to be here and we can ask well
what if it was you know
even more maximally violated uh we would
get to the standpoint that uh that we
you know we may not exist either in
other words it's dangerous to invoke
things like um you know anthropic or
existence proofs but the fact that we
exist has to be taken to account when
assessing some of the likelihood of
these laws to actually be valid now in
the case of the parody violation uh in
your you know string of tweets that kind
of you know motivated me to to include
in my video about um madame wu shinsen
woos a famous experiment that validated
you know less than a few weeks after uh
le yang and and uh lee came up with this
prediction uh her vid i'll have a link
to the video up here somewhere
but that uh i go in to talk about that
parody is violated maximally and you go
into detail as to why that is i wonder
if you could recapitulate that for the
for the listeners
um
what does it mean to be maximally
maximally violated
well
it so
it's it's not just a subtle effect right
when you look at the the weak
interaction it's it's just blatant it's
it's not like um
you look in the mirror and it's it's one
in a billion
um events looks like it doesn't obey
parity it's every single time so so when
i take my mirror view of the universe
and look at the weak interaction it
always
it disagrees with what i see in my
universe so it could have been subtle
right it could have been so subtle that
it could have been just one decay in a
billion would would look weird but it's
not it's every single one of them
so again why is parity violated at that
particular level and again
and where is this written into the
fabric of the universe
where is it where
where does the universe need to know
that it definitely has a right and
definitely has unless not a little bit
right and a little bit left but
definitely right definitely left so it
is it is
um
again one of those deep mysteries that
that does bother me somewhat it keeps me
awake at night
yeah it's it is fascinating and that
these you know at some level rely on
these particles which you also talk
about
in in the book these neutrinos and how
how stunningly important they are even
though by far a million times less
massive than uh than the most massive or
least massive other particle the
electron and i always get kind of tired
of it you know like carl sagan saying
things like as much as i love carl and
respect him i've had his widow andrew
ian on the podcast his daughter sasha
sagan on the so i have utmost respect
what do you say things like oh you look
into the cosmos and see how
insignificant we are
uh and you know so what size scale would
we be important like is jupiter
important as a is a neutron star like
what level of size do we have to be if
as you point out neutrinos are these
insignificant ghost particles and yet
they play this inordinate amount of a
role in our in their composition of our
universe so maybe
can you wax poetically about what
neutrinos mean to you in the cosmos
including these symmetry principles
which they seemingly uniquely reveal
yeah so yeah neutrinos again um
again
my my
deep down sort of wish or you know about
the universe is that really that
neutrinos hold the key that they they
even though they are seemingly
inconsequential particles
there's something about the neutrino
which is tender something deep about the
universe so you mentioned about parity
being
maximally uh violated right so we we
know that we have lots of different
kinds of particles in the universe and
the neutrino is not that dissimilar to
the photon the particle of light the
neutrinos got a teeny bit of mass the
photon's got no mass
but the the photon it has also has spin
and a photon can spin this way and it
can spin that way perfectly fine it's
symmetric in terms of its parity right
you look at a photon in the mirror it's
spinning the opposite direction that's
fine i've got photons like that in the
universe
neutrinos though
always spin the same way
right so and i i i can never look at the
right hand and lectures i'll teach you
how jaren are you ready yeah so light
you know that the double helix which
we'll get to in a minute dna is life
right life is always right life is
always right
okay and then neutrinos are always the
opposite of life so genos are only
left-handed yeah neutrinos and
right-handed anti-neutrinos and dna is
only right and there is no left-handed
dna that's my hospital monotonic to
teach you okay one of my favorite
professors so i feel good now okay good
so so the the reason that uh you know uh
wu's experiment showed the result that
it did is that neutrinos are always born
left-handed they're always born with the
same spin
and again you can ask yourself
what tells them when they're born that
they all have to spin in this particular
direction and all anti-neutrinos spin in
the opposite direction
and
it's it's somewhere there in the weak
interaction and what we've had to do
with our mathematics is we've basically
had to write that in right we've had to
write that all neutrinos are left-handed
all anti-neutrinos are right-handed
but that
spin
says gives a definite handedness to the
universe right it does imprint a
handedness because everybody would agree
that all neutrinos are spinning this the
same way
and there have been links between the
spin of the neutrino
and
us being alive here on the planet right
because we are
handed creatures right we our molecules
tend to have a preferred
handedness to them and so you can have a
molecule which is that looks like this
and you have the same molecule same
atoms et cetera but the mirror image of
it and your body will use one and it
will ignore the other because you are
built out of
handed molecules with a handiness
and people have suggested that the
reason that we have this uh handedness
to our molecules is due to the weak
interaction occurring somewhere in the
early universe or in the early life of
the earth that basically twists
molecules in a certain way
lots of hand waving involved in all of
this but we might be here living the way
that
we are living because of this
fundamental aspect of the universe that
it knows right from left
which is i made a video about that too
i'll put that link over here somewhere
too yeah the life
and the weakened direction yeah it's an
intriguing story and again you know my
hope is that that at some level that
there's some truth in that of course
there are lots of people that don't like
to tie fundamental physics to life in
that manner and there's lots of things
about whether it was polarization in
early star form in regions etc but i do
like the the the notion that we are
essentially the weak force writ large at
some level right
right and that the weak force is
responsible for us living and again it's
also kind of maximally violated in that
we only see one form of dna and we only
see one form of neutrinos so
yes but you know it's dangerous equating
you know two things that are equal
except for those that vanish or
something like that all banishing all
zeros are equivalent um so getting back
uh into the book what's what's so you
know kind of delightful to me is that it
kind of picks up in some sense um you
know where the previous book left off in
other words last time you were kind of
concerned with well somebody writes to
you or to me
and says you know professor i've got
this great idea and um you know the way
the universe was born and it doesn't
involve any of the known laws of physics
and i'll share my nobel prize with you
professor lewis but you got to help me
with the math
um and uh et cetera and then you see you
come up with this rubric or you know
what you refer back to michael keys and
his paper systemizing the theoretical
virtues i wonder if you could do the
same you know for some of the more
speculative things that you talk about
in the book such as the theory of
everything such as you know entanglement
and the kind of more speculative aspects
of physics where do these where would
these fair
uh as a cosmic you know revolutionary
how would these this book fair against
the old the previous book
well well okay so
what's the goal of of this book of
course was to try and present
how we actually understand
how how things work right so that there
are various complicated things that
occur in the universe where you have
gravity and quantum mechanics and
they're doing their stuff to make things
like stars and the expanding universe
etc
what we didn't want to do in too much
detail in the book though is go into
how we know those things
are the best description right we didn't
want to write a history of uh the
development of the you know modern
theory of star um stellar evolution etc
because that's already been done so this
was to to to tell people this is this is
how we understand things work
at the moment with the theories that we
have but as you mentioned we wanted also
to get across that that the story isn't
over we haven't got
all the answers yet so at some level i
guess there is a bit of an invitation
in there for people to think about oh
what would be the next step but what i
would hope is that they would go back to
our previous book and understand that if
they do have a new idea that there's a
process by which you go through if your
idea is scientific for it to you know
have an impact on the community rather
than write in surreptitiously to various
professors offering shares of nobel
prizes
and i kind of could comment on with that
there's always this question of
you know who is
doing what you know so you're asking
someone's asking where did the universe
come from you know can it be answered
can it not be answered um we had paul
davies on recently about what's eating
the universe uh we've had on mario
olivia of our why you know so all these
questions right but those always
presuppose some kind of consciousness
and some sort of entity and even you
know not withstanding the difficulties
of quantum mechanical interpretation
um still the notion of consciousness uh
and it's in its role with regard to can
we recognize the theory of everything
i've heard people say you know if we if
life existed in the universe paul talks
about the shadow biosphere and things
like that you know maybe it's right in
front of our face maybe we we haven't
already is there any danger like do we
have
like just an impediment to possibly
not seeing you know answers to certain
questions because we don't understand
the role of this ultimate observer this
three pound super computer you know in
our heads the role of consciousness or
is can we divorce consciousness from you
know the observer from the observed and
then you know in so doing answer these
questions these ultimate existential
questions
uh this is something that i've turned
over in my mind a lot in the last couple
of years so the
the
the super computer in your in your head
um
we've come an awful lot awfully long way
in the last you know few tens of
thousands of years right
and
[Music]
at some level it is rather astonishing
that this
brain that essentially evolved
originally in africa to live on the
plains and then has gone around the
world etc
uh but you know it it's there for our
survival right so charlie lineweaver anu
is you know has
spoken about this thing
you know is intelligence an evolutionary
goal and he basically says no you know
we are a fluke right we've we've we
became intelligent because it helped us
to survive
but that doesn't explain why we then
could turn that intelligence to the
universe and ask questions like where
did the universe come from that's not
really helping us in the survival thing
and we've done that in the last few few
tens of thousands of years
my worry is of course there's a couple
of things number one is that we have to
at some level appreciate that there is a
limited compute power up there right so
you you can never you'll never out
out think a true super computer
in terms of raw calculations but there
is another ingredient the consciousness
the the you know the ability to come up
with new and novel ideas and people are
questioning whether you know artificial
intelligence is going to have that
ability if artificial intelligence is
ever going to have the ability to come
up with something new
or will everything artificial
intelligence do just be um built on a
theme that's been fed into it kind of
thing
and i i really
i really don't know i i've seen
arguments both ways but one of the
arguments that that does sort of freak
me out slightly is this question of
if we do get a really smart ai
and it does come up with you know the
the the next level theory that we will
not understand it right whether we will
just not be able to comprehend what we
are being told and this is not a new
thing right we've we've had this problem
with computers in the past in the sense
that computers come up with solutions to
problems and we look at them and we just
go
where did this solution come from and
even how does it work you know how does
the solution actually
actually work and it's only going to
become
murkier and murkier as the problems
become more complicated and complex etc
so yeah we we might we might
we might have a computer that solves
everything
and we just might not understand what
it's telling us and again
what do we do at that point it might
just look like gibrish to us but it
might be the theory of everything
yeah
yeah i've had some you know kind of
thoughts about that i don't know if
you've heard my spiels but um
but you know kind of the ai
einstein or you know aion galileo i
always have to have my finger puppets
you'll remember these guys
so einstein
i'm sure you've heard the story that
he called the realization that someone
in free fall would experience no
gravitational force he called that the
happiest thought of his life
and of course that led to the
underpinnings of the you know weak
equivalence principle and from that
comes gr
when you're married to special
relativity and a lot of differential
geometry and other cool things um when
we talk about that though it's not clear
that an artificial intelligent
agent could a
have a happy thought you know
what does that even mean and then b you
know visualize you know this free fall
experience which is you know kind of
extra sensory and and kind of uh you
know revolves around a lot of
experiential
almost wisdom which by definition i
don't think uh silicon agents can have
or even you know quantum you know bose
einstein condensate computers could have
or whatever you have so the one since
i'm not i'm more pessimistic about ai
physicists but i do share one thing um
in resonance with what you just said
which is you know could we recognize it
or distinguish from gibberish
so thinking about that question i've
often heard it said you know
uh neil degrasse tyson who was a guest
on the show and and hopefully we'll be
back again soon you know he says like
well you know if you don't believe in
science whatever that means yeah like
you're using a transistor right now you
know like you're talking to me on zoom
or you know zencaster or whatever you're
using an iphone you're like so you don't
trust the same people that looked into
the laws of quantum mechanics and made
that transistor but now you think
they're going to lie to you about x y or
z and i always have to kind of push back
on that because i don't think anybody
look if you've ever seen the pictures of
the first transistor you know bardeen
and shockley and um and others coop not
cooper uh um
blacking on the third guy but anyway uh
they invented the transistor you know
it's like chewing gum and a coat hanger
and a big piece of silicon and it looks
nothing like you know what you'd see in
you know schrodinger's equation now
tells you what the uh you know how this
device is going to perform
no it's built from experimentation
similarly people say well thanks to
einstein and e equals m c squared we
unlock the power of the atom bomb and
and you talk about this in your book you
know the super symmetry string theoretic
if we do have a theory of everything
what will it do for us and some people
say well like it could unleash the
equivalent
of you know destructive power on the
earth that you know dynamite did
compared to nuclear power and then
nuclear power compared to whatever the
theory of everything will unlock if you
believe
that is a possibility like that merely
the equations
can actually lead to technology i find
them very separate i feel i find that
distinction is very arbitrary the people
say because we understood uh you know
because we under we understood evolution
we now can you know we now have crispr i
think they're very different
yeah
so
i don't have to tell you here right
science is a lot messier than the
the textbook portrayal right and you
know the the
uh wash rinse repeat kind of idea that
that we wake up in the morning the first
thing we say to ourselves today what's
my hypothesis right and off we go
we know that's not how it works and we
also know that you know the
experimentalists they tinker and they
play and they they try and find things
out and it's a game at some level right
but it's right
but it is a guided game in the sense
that
you do look at what other people
have done and you think about how i
could push an experiment this way or
that way et cetera so there is sort of a
relationship there
i do think equations
carry power in themselves in that you
know um right and this is what i say to
my my students you know you
you may have experienced this the
transition of a student from like a a
student into a research student when
they stop
you know they derive
an equation they give you the answer
right but when they derive an equation
and ask them what's the consequences of
that equation right that's when they you
know move into that research sort of
area
consequences come from examining the
equations and some of those consequences
can be good and some of those uh are not
necessarily that good
e equals mc squared was was definitely a
driver in the development of nuclear
physics i think that's almost
undoubted but of course at the time uh
even when equals mc squared was
uh was published i think it was
rutherford who said that anyone who says
that you could get usable power from an
atom is talking moonshine right so
different people have different
interpretations i guess of how powerful
an equation can be but i think it can be
can be motivated
but as i said science is a bit of
tinkering over here a bit of maths over
there sometimes it comes together
sometimes it doesn't but it sort of also
heaves itself forward
yeah exactly and um i guess you know i
always like to you know again i want the
readers to buy this book and read it in
as many formats as possible um and i
guess you know the the question is not
maybe where the universe is you know is
coming from that has to be answered and
i think you know it's really that the
title is really a descriptor i mean you
go through here and you kind of you know
kind of gave me flashbacks to high
school chemistry you know you were going
through a hund's rules and you know how
do you get these uh the different
packings but you go through in really
delightful detail on how
the universe is really assembled put
together if you will um
and and yet i think you do make this
convincing case that there's a lot left
to be
to be discovered and that we are kind of
scratching the surface and that you know
to some people is depressing because we
spend so much time so much money and so
many people we only have so much of all
these things and yet there are still so
many mysteries left to do but i think
that's also what makes it exciting and i
guess if i ask you you know of the
questions that you pose and sort of put
forth here you know it's like children
you can never say you know which one's
your favorite but
is there kind of a question bucket list
question that you would like to ask
the almighty um or you know that you
most are interested in understanding i
mean you mentioned the weak force
earlier but could you put a spin on to
no pun intended
why that is and kind of what the most
ultimate satisfaction for you
would be to answer in your career or
have answered in your career oh so in my
career so we are talking about very very
uh earthly kind of things so i guess one
of the one of my driving forces in my
research is you know the dark side of
the universe that's the that's the area
that i think
could be answered in my lifetime at
least part of it right so we we we know
that we have dark matter we have dark
energy and
we've known about dark matter for
rapidly approaching 100 years if you
look back at as wiki's original work
uh dark energy you know theoretically
for a bunch of years but last 20 years
something is out there
i think that given the effort around the
globe trying to answer these questions
that we will
come to some sort of a conclusion at
least around dark matter right i mean
the particle physicists are going you
know full guns the astronomers and now
the astro particle physicists looking
for signatures of what dark matter might
be
dark energy i think is going to be a
tougher nut to crack
in that
all the
all the observations so far are pushing
towards dark energy being maximally
boring
in the sense that it's looking more and
more like einstein's
traditional cosmological constant
and if that's what it is
then it's some background to the
universe that we're never going gonna
get to play with we're never gonna get
to manipulate we're just gonna have to
shrug our shoulders and say
it's there but people are really looking
for any signature whatsoever that
there's a a deviation from that kind of
simple picture but the the results out
by the the pantheon people this week
we are heading towards a maximally
boring universe and that that that's
actually one of my fears right because
after you've nailed down the equation of
state to five decimal places how much
further do you go right one point zero
zero minus one point zero zero zero zero
zero zero
wha what do you do at that point and
we're not there yet but it just feels
like we're going down that road
yeah now that is true and yeah may it be
you know maybe you live in boring times
on earth at least but
perhaps cosmologically interesting times
so jared we've reached the end of the
scheduled conversation but there is a
bonus uh portion which i like to call
the thrilling three the impossible
questions which i didn't ask you guys
last time because it was two of you got
and i think it would be very difficult
to ask two people you know three
questions each so i would like to ask
you some existential questions uh about
where you have come from and where you
are going if you don't mind let's go for
it
all right so the first question uh has
to do with your near-term future
although i hope not for you know 80
years or so and when you reach the
biblical
ordained maximal age as we scientists
know that's when our lives come to an
end at 120 when
the rabbi moses came to his end um he
left an ethical will kind of a a bit of
wisdom and intelligence i see you as a
seeker as a thinker not just kind of a a
technician i think that you think big
big thoughts and that's the kind of
guest i love to have on this on this
podcast i want to ask you this question
when you reach the biblical age of 120
what piece of wisdom not monetary not
knowledge what wisdom would you put in
your ethical will to give as wisdom for
future generations
oh what wisdom oh my goodness
uh
my i think
my my my
the two bits and pieces number one
i i really think it is be kind
i i don't care what what your occupation
is around and what country or clan
you're
claimed to be part of i think be kind
and uh it's because i think we lose
track of the fact that other people are
people and they are dealing with their
lives and nobody's life is simple
but the other is is to be curious
i i again i i do sometimes worry about
the
the state of um
not just scientific knowledge but the
approach to science by governments and
that sets the scientific knowledge and
this notion of being curious for
curious sake to try and understand the
deeper questions about the universe i
think
is is very important
there is more to life than just
developing the next widget the next
iphone the next ipad
answering these bigger questions i think
is something that is it should be our
goal as human beings
you're speaking my language literally
because the motto of my youtube channel
is abc
always be curious all right excellent
okay
now i want to go uh farther into the
future
and this is going to take us along the
lines of sir arthur c clarke's 2001 a
space odyssey where these monoliths make
their appearance i don't know if you've
seen it or not okay
so these we don't know what they are
maybe their time capsules maybe their
warnings maybe they're kind of uh you
know someone's putting it there to brag
but i want to ask a question as if
they're time capsules and and ask you
what you put in it uh kind of a time
capsule that you knew would last a
billion years and it's not too
dissimilar from richard feynman's kind
of what he called this cataclysm
question like what would you put uh you
know what what's word what sentence
contains the most information about the
physical universe in the fewest possible
words so to speak and he mentioned atoms
but i want to ask you what would you put
in a time capsule that summarizes
everything we've learned about the
cosmos not you specifically but about
you know humankind as a whole
ah so again that's a tricky question
that one is
um
i don't think i have a very simple
answer to this i think what i think if i
was going to leave a message
to
the at any future creature that found
this this capsule
uh i think it would be that that we were
proud that we've learned so much in such
little time and again maybe we want a
summary of what we know there but i
think the fact that that as slightly
evolved monkey brains have achieved so
much in a few tens of thousands of years
is something that we should be proud of
and again as as charlie lineweaver says
intelligence might be a rare thing in
the universe and it might be that we are
freaky that we've developed it's
relatively fast
so
yeah i i
i i don't know if i could i could write
anything down that a creature billions
of years from now would go oh i didn't
know that
but i think i would write down something
about being proud about what we have
achieved
yeah it's very beautiful
and speak for yourself when you talk
about monkey brains okay uh last
question has to do
with uh you're not your future or the
universe's future but your past
and this has to do with sir arthur c
clarke's so-called third law which is
the only way of discovering the limits
of the possible is to venture a little
way past them into the impossible of
course that's the name of my podcast
origin into the impossible which we take
from uh sir arthur and i ask you what
mysterious aspect of life perhaps as a
scientist or not uh perplexed you as a
20 year old 30 year old what have you
but now makes kind of sense looking back
with the aid of time and space
what kind of advice might you give to
that 20 or 30 year old person to give
him the courage to go into the
impossible
oh
again another question i i don't know if
i've
i'd say i don't know if i've answered
any of my questions that i had when i
was a 20 year old to do with
with with life i mean i i as as a as a
young man i was bothered by the
questions i think that everyone's
bothered by i am still bothered by the
existence of consciousness
and i i i don't know whether or not i
should
be uh bothered about
um
and the other one of course is is is
pain
you know when you realize that pain
doesn't exist
right it's not pain is not you know it's
a signal right
it's your interpretation of that and you
sort of what
that makes no sense to me in terms of
evolution of why
pain is what it is as a evolutionary
survival thing but then why other things
feel painful which don't necessarily
help your survival
again is a little bit uncertain are you
talking about faculty meetings what are
you talking about yeah i'm talking about
i'm currently dealing with um
astropolitics at the moment and it is
very painful
um
i don't know i don't know i i
i always knew you know you wanted to be
a scientist no i didn't i i i i almost
fell into this role more than anything i
i don't come from a scientific
background my father was a coal miner um
i i didn't know any scientists
um
i did i did enjoy science
and i guess one of the things that i
would have told myself back then is to
understand that we really do not know
everything
because often science was portrayed you
know you watch a scientific documentary
you read an article in new scientists
often it's about oh look this is all the
stuff we understand and really what
drives me now of course is that stuff
that we don't understand
and we
i would
i would
tell my younger self know to seek out
what it is we don't know don't don't
just rely on what we're told we do know
tell me how did a coal miner son uh grow
up to be uh you know from from wales uh
grow up to be a professor and such a
good communicator and writer especially
you're the only commonality between the
two books of
yours i've read
nothing against uh luke or chris
certainly but you're the only common
author between so how'd you be how did a
coal miner son from
south wales become such a erudite
scholar
um i was let's see
i mean i went to high school and it was
only in high school i discovered that i
could do mathematics
and i enjoyed physics and it was in high
school my
my fellow students were starting to talk
about going to university so i thought
well maybe i should do that too and so i
went off to university and i i did
physics and astronomy i i thought i'd do
physics because i could get a job
somewhere and i did astronomy as as out
of interest and i did well and so
you know as i approached the end of my
degree somebody said oh are you thinking
of doing a phd and i mean i guess i am
and i applied to do a phd so it was
there was never a grand plan it was more
of a
an amble and by and accidental paths and
anything else
and yeah i i never planned to be a
professor
i just randomly ended up at cambridge
and then
stony brook which is where i had my
origin story but that's a tale for
another podcast anyway
it's a thrill to talk to you i hope we
do get to meet when you come up over
from down under uh perhaps this year
will be the end of this this pandemic
and we'll be able to meet finally and
maybe do a live podcast in person at
some point that'll be a thrill that
would be wonderful thank you
thank you so much so tell folks where
they can find you on and about the
internet uh so i'm on twitter at cosmic
underscore horizons
and i have a web page www.garenfluis.com
but i'm happy to answer questions on
twitter or even posted through the
website
as long as they passed the rubric of
your previous book uh karen thank you so
much it's been a treat and i hope we can
meet up and uh and do it again sometime
soon see you soon
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you